dimanche lui j'essaie de saint-quentin
accueillait jamel debbouze trappistes
d'origine et l'équipe du film la marche
à l'occasion d'une projection en avant
première un long métrage librement
inspiré de la marche pour l'égalité et
contre le racisme mouvement qui trente
ans plus tôt dénoncé les conditions des
immigrés en france une marche pacifiste
parti de marseille le 15 octobre 1983
pour rejoindre paris avec un cortège de
cent mille personnes en décembre c'est
une histoire assez extraordinaire devoir
déjà inspiré par le dandy qui décide
d'organiser une marche non violente pour
l'égalité et contre le racisme ça
résonne mais c'est avant tout un sujet
cinématographique en or qui plus est une
histoire vraie donc je pense que
malheureusement ou heureusement pour
certains les agents d'un concorde et on
se dit que ce film a besoin d'être je
maintenant besoin d'être vu maintenant
peut-être parce que le film soulève la
question du sens des 30 ans de la marche
aujourd'hui la france at-elle changé
plein de choses ont changé la preuve on
fait un film aujourd'hui est comme ça il
y a
il ya un millier de choses qui ont été
faites aujourd'hui il suffit de regarder
les journaux pour voir les personnages
mais les personnalités préférées des
français on a au mas on n'a jamais le
gade tout et jean d'aider des enfants
d'immigrés le racisme il est il et il
est présent chez certains français mais
la france n'est pas un pays raciste et
film en tout cas nous on essaie de le
démontrer la france n'est pas raciste
sac immature bientôt les clés à la même
heure au même moment pour les
municipales ou à la veille de chaque
élection on ressasse les mêmes trucs à
nous est pas tombé dedans ça ne pas
accorder de crédit à jean marine le pen
ce qu'indiquent des bêtises c'est son
père avec avec des cheveux vous n'avez
pas eu pour vous faire vous faire
et puis si ces journaux claques ont-ils
apporté pour les connaît depuis les
années le fait d'en parler ça fait
vendre c'est pas inquiétant pour
l'instant la seule chose qui m'inquiète
c'est effectivement le chômage chez les
infirmières qui se plaignent celui-ci
les routiers qui deviennent fous c'est
les agriculteurs qui sont tous ça c'est
inquiétant la crise économique est
vraiment inquiétante et souvent ça va de
pair alors ne le font non pas
la crise et le racisme sortie nationale
du film le 27 novembre